when i pick them up i feel like they
borrowed when i got a return i'm
scanning like a barcode kanye west isn't
holding back about the impact his
ongoing divorce with kim kardashian has
had on their kids all in his new track
true love
[Music]
yay dropped the song on friday just do
something for my heart a collab with
late rapper xxx tentacion where he gives
fans a glimpse of life behind the scenes
with his and kim's four little ones
north saint chicago and saul i only see
three kids who watch in chicago and you
know all the nannies that
[Music]
and get this he even raps about his
struggles with their co-parenting
arrangement wait when you see the kids i
see y'all tomorrow wait when the sun set
i see y'all tomorrow wait when i pick em
up i feel like they borrowed when i got
a return i'm scanned em like a barcode
but this isn't yay's first time rapping
about his new family dynamic remember
easy the collab with the game he dropped
in march
cousin dre send me scriptures help me
see life better
we having the best divorce ever if we go
to court we'll go to court together
matter of fact pick up your sister go to
courts together yeah and on hulu's the
kardashians kim reacts to the rapper
dropping a new single and while it's
unclear if they're talking specifically
about easy based on the timeline it's a
pretty good guess kanye's coming out
with a new rap song what does that mean
it means he's talking mad about me and
most men are not trashing
like the mother of their kids like that
publicly the tracks music video is
bizarre and violent it features a
claymation version of kim's bow pete
davidson god sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
and while kim knows she can't control
the situation she still apologizes to
her family i can't control what other
people do how he treats me
you know or how he's always treated you
guys i do recognize the impact that my
relationship has had on my family and
i've never had the opportunity to just
say i'm sorry guys
but her fam comes to her defense the
truth always prevails so karma is always
going to be on your side yeah and you'll
never regret being a good person you
never stoop to other people
and chloe's right kim hasn't stooped
instead it seems like she's living her
best life with pete by her side what do
you love about him what's your favorite
thing about it he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and watch tv and
just do nothing
that's my favorite thing
[Music]
you